[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 60,18 le tour de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite lé titre de cette édition du
mercredi 10 avril saint quentin en
yvelines rejoint activitiés
l'agglomération a adhéré hier à l'agencé
départementale d'insertion
professionnelle depuis 2015 elle
accompagne les bénéficiaires du rsa pour
retrouver une activité salariée le
territoire saint quentinois représente
plus de 26 % de l'emploi dans les
yvelines
après trois mois de grands débats
l'heure est au bilan la phase de
restitution a débuté lundi les
revendications des gilets jaunes qui ont
conduit à l'organisation de cette
consultation ont-elles été prises en
compte nous en parlons en plateau et
puis elle était une grande dame du
cinéma agnès varda est décédé le 29 mars
dernier en 2000 le verrier roi alain
fonteneau apparaissait dans son
documentaire les glaneurs et la glaneuse
dans ce journal il revient sur cette
expérience avec la réalisatrice
à suivre également un point sur les
métiers de la banque 575 places seront
ouvertes en alternance à la rentrée de
septembre en ile-de-france a mené les
bénéficiaires du rsa à l'emploi la
mission d' activity lagence d'insertion
professionnelle du département compte
est depuis hier à un nouvel adhérent
saint quentin en yvelines les précisions
dans ce sujet de nicolas landry et de
mélanie poker activity à un nouvel
adhérent lagence d'insertion
professionnelle du département accueille
depuis hier
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le territoire de saint quentin
c'est avec le territoire de la vallée de
la seine le territoire willy à la fois
le plus grand nombre des bénéficiaires
du rsa mais aussi où il ya le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises et à dynamisme
entrepreneurial qui est très marquée une
volonté de la communauté d'agglomération
d'accompagner d'avoir une vraie
compétence emploi il à prendre à bras le
corps
saint quentin en yvelines ses dix sept
mille entreprises et plus de 23 mille
postes non pourvus activités travaille
sur des remises à niveau et des
qualifications deux personnes éloignées
de l'emploi
je rentre au conseil d'administration
donc déjà on va avoir avoir un regard
croisé de notre territoire par rapport à
ce que eux ils amènent et puis nous
qu'est ce que nous pouvons apporter
on sait qu'on a des poches
très complexe au niveau des douze
communes on sait qu'on a des quartiers
on a eu huit upv sur notre territoire
sur ces 8 pb on sait bien qu'il ya des
actions et qui sont menées et plutôt
bien mené il y en a d'autres qui
demandent à être revitalisé dans ces
quartiers prioritaires 5% des actifs ont
un faible niveau de qualification
saint quentin en yvelines représente
plus de 26 % de l'emploi sur le
département
mais on reparlera insertion
professionnelle et emploi tout à l'heure
dans ce journal
à l'heure du bilan pour le grand débat
national cette grande phase de
consultation a duré deux mois du 15
janvier au 15 mars près de deux millions
de contributions ont été formulées et
depuis lundi le gouvernement a débuté à
7 phases une phase de restitution de ce
grand débat on en parle avec vous sa
fille à mathari bonsoir ça vous êtes
gilet jaune des yvelines alors le
gouvernement qui organisait ce grand
débat en réponse à la mobilisation des
gilets jaunes qui dure depuis le 17
novembre un acte 22 est d'ailleurs
prévue ce samedi est très avril déjà
d'un point de vue global sur ce grand
débat est-ce qu'il a été utile à vos
yeux ou non edouard philippe le premier
ministre parle en tout cas d'une
réussite de ce grand débat national
oui edouard philippe va pas dire que ça
a été un échec puisque
c'est le gouvernement qui a lancé ce
grand débat donc se seraient ils ont un
peu de mal à avouer leur échec j'ai
l'impression qu'il vaut mieux il n'a pas
été très utile dans le sens où il n'y a
pas eu énormément de mobilisation sur ce
grand débat les thèmes étaient imposées
il y avait des questionnaires avec des
questions fermées quelques questions
verte
mais les statistiques ont démontré qu'il
n'y avait pas eu énormément de réponses
à ces questions verte près de deux
millions de contributions pour vous
c'est pas suffisant c'est ça montre pas
peut-être la réussite du grand débat du
coup en fait 2 millions de contributions
ces deux millions de réponses mais c'est
pas forcément 2 millions de français qui
ont participé à de grands départements
et les contributeurs qui ont répondu à
l'ensemble du questionnaire représente
moins de quarante mille personnes et
vous le dites des thèmes qui sont pas
forcément les plus importants aux yeux
en tout cas des français et on voit
d'ailleurs dans les contributions qui
ont été formulées dans ce grand débat
que quatre thèmes ont émergé
spontanément des thèmes qui n'était pas
prévu à la base pour par le gouvernement
le pouvoir d'achat la solidarité santé
l'éducation et l'emploi donc ça montre
que dès le début le gouvernement n'avait
pas cibler les bons thèmes peut-être oui
effectivement les thèmes étaient pas
cibler correctement
je pense que le gouvernement a voulu
cibler des thèmes qui l'intéressait
puisqu'on sait que les annonces que
monsieur maquereau a faite début
décembre suite à la crise et gilet jaune
étaient des annonces de dax d'action qui
était déjà prévu dans le calendrier du
gouvernement est donc là le grand débat
très clairement c était pour appuyer la
politique du président dans les
contributions il ya eu en tout cas un
consensus soit 69% des contributeurs
souhaite la reconnaissance du vote blanc
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ce chiffre
bas c'est important les français en
faisant participer à la démocratie
si on est en démocratie il faut qu'on
puisse s'exprimer il faut qu'on puisse
avoir des outils
donc effectivement c'est très important
mais ya pas que ça il ya aussi le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
est important et qui a été une fois de
plus écrasé par ce grand débat et puis
pas d'ailleurs dans les premières
contributions seulement 5,8 pour cent
les contributeurs ont mis en davantage
en avant un autre référendum ce qui est
déjà en place celui d'initiative
partagée
il souhaiterait le voir renforcée oui
bah on pourra en parler mais ce
référendum là il n'a pas énormément de
chance d'aboutir
concrètement fait il est très difficile
à mettre en place donc c'est à ça me
paraît assez compliqué et c'est voilà
c'est pas quelque chose qui est facile à
mettre en place pour il faut défendre
justement le rique celui qui est mise en
avant dans ces mobilisations des gilets
jaunes ce référendum référendum pardon
d'initiative citoyenne
mais en fait le rics un très bon outil
s'il est en toute matière et sans
limitation pas ce qui permet aux
citoyens de faire de la politique sans
devenir un élu et ça permet aux citoyens
de contrôler le travail de deux de ses
élus de ses représentants dont qui
travaille comme pour nous il travaille
pas pour eux
et à partir du moment où on peut
contrôler leur travail forcément ça va
les motiver à travailler mieux alors des
propositions claires en tout cas pas
encore émergé
ça devrait arriver de par la suite par
le gouvernement d'ailleurs à côté de ce
grand débat les gilets jaunes ont
organisé leur vrai débat vous étiez
d'ailleurs réuni le 22 février pour un
débat à elancourt quelles sont les
propositions du cou qui émerge de ce
vrai débat des gilet jaune quel sont les
thèmes qui reviennent
eh bien il ya des thèmes tels que le
hérissé donc le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qui lui ressort énormément
donc ça nous paraît assez curieux
puisque on a l'impression en fait que le
gouvernement fait une campagne de
dénigrement de se hérisser en disant que
ça va être compliqué que il va y avoir
des référendum toutes les semaines alors
que concrètement c'est impossible et
c'est pas vrai donc le hérissé ressorti
la justice fiscale est pas la baisse des
impôts parce que baisser les impôts
c'est bien mais rendre de la justice
c'est mieux l'écologie aussi ressort pas
mal
et puis tout ce qui est solidarité avec
le chômage les retraites et la santé
alors si on parle de la suite de la
mobilisation des gilet jaune on l'a dit
elle dure depuis le 17 novembre un acte
22 est prévue ce week-end et c'est vrai
que ces dernières semaines on a tendance
à mettre en avant davantage on a parlé
davantage des violences alors côté des
casseurs mais aussi côté des forces de
l'ordre les violences des forces de
l'ordre plutôt que du fond finalement
pourquoi il faut encore se mobiliser
pour quoi les gilet jaune se mobilisent
encore on se mobilisent parce qu'on n'a
pas de réponse ça fait cinq mois qu'on
est mobilisés donc on va pas s'arrêter
au bout de cinq mois
on n'a pas de réponse à nos demandes
ça fait cinq mois qu'on est dans la rue
ça fait cinq mois qu'on passe sur les
plateaux de télé ça fait cinq mois qu'on
organise des réunions publiques gilet
jaune mais ouverte à tous donc les élus
peuvent y participer peuvent venir
peuvent venir nous écouter et et on en
fait on n'est pas écoutés du tout donc
le grand débat ça a été quelque chose
qui a été fait pour à mes yeux à me sens
ralentir un petit peu les seins des
lèvres là jusqu'aux élections
européennes d'ailleurs toutes les
interventions monsieur macron devant les
maires vont être décompté du temps de
parole des européennes de son parti
parfum de l'exécutif par le csa l'a dit
donc c'est ça montre bien voilà que
c'est une sorte de campagne et nous on
n'attend pas du président qui continue à
faire sa campagne on attend du présent
qui réponde à nos demandes
l'un des combats actuels c'est l'un des
prochains en tout cas c'est la
privatisation l'aéroport de grand pas de
d'aéroports de paris vous êtes opposé à
cette privatisation oui on est opposé
donc à la loi pacte dans la loi pacte il
ya des choses qui sont bien et il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont pas
terribles telle cette privatisation donc
le problème c'est qu'une loi on est
obligé de la prendre dans son ensemble
donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est carrément
que la loi pacte entière soit revue on a
fait des manifestations devant
l'assemblée nationale donc en mars
lorsque le texte a été lu
semblait et mardi dernier donc
avant-hier au sénat hier pardon au sénat
devant le sénat on a manifesté également
et donc on est très content de voir
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des députés qui qui
qui signe pour qu'un référendum
d'initiative partagée puisse être lancé
mais ce référendum là il va être très
compliqué obtenir puisqu'on a la
signature des députés maintenant il va
falloir que le conseil constitutionnel
valide la question référendaire et
ensuite que 4,5 millions d'électeurs
valide le fait qu'on puisse poser cette
question référendaire ou comment cette
nouvelle proposition de loi soit soit
discutée à l'assemblée pendant six mois
et après ces six mois si l'assemblée n'a
pas décidé c'est là qu'on a un
référendum fin c'est hyper hyper
compliqué merci satyam atari et je
rappelle que vous êtes gilet jaune des
yvelines vous parliez justement de cette
privatisation d'aéroports de paris ne
veulent pas de cette privatisation 197
parlementaires de gauche et de droite
confondues ont signé une proposition
pour lancer vous en parliez safia
mathari de ce référendum d'initiative
partagée sur la question pour rappel la
privatisation du groupe aéroportuaire
est l'une des mesures phares de la loi
pacte il autoriserait l'état à vendre
une partie ou la totalité de ses actifs
dans l'entreprise le texte doit être
adopté définitivement par le parlement
cette semaine par l'assemblée nationale
pour qu'un référendum soit organisé
il faut que la proposition soit validée
par le conseil d'état puis signé par au
moins 10 % du corps électoral français
adp a dans les yvelines la gestion des
aérodromes de toussus-le-noble saint cyr
ou encore chavenay villepreux installé
développer son activité en pleine nature
c'est le choix fait il ya trois ans par
plus de 80 entrepreneurs yvelinois à
feucherolles la briqueterie est une
pépinière d'entreprises où l'on retrouve
ateliers d'artistes créateurs ou société
de conseil un lieu que vous fait
découvrir aux rayons ce
de la verdure et des chants d'oiseaux
pour cadre de travail
bienvenue à la briqueterie il y a trois
ans cette pépinière d'entreprises a
investi cette ancienne briqueterie du
19e siècle situé à feucherolles pour la
petite histoire ce lieu a accueilli le
tournage d'une des dernières scènes des
tontons flingueurs le film culte de
georges lautner en 1963 aujourd'hui dans
ce parc de deux hectares près de 90
locataires sont répartis dans trois
bâtiments
ici vous avez patty canac qui est
parfumeur aromatologue et qui
travaillent les huiles essentielles
carla sanchez qui a deux casquettes mais
bien distinctes
elle est créatrice de bijoux et en même
temps elle est artiste peint batissiel
dont ce nouveau bâtiment créateurs
artistes ou encore société de bien-être
se côtoient il y un peu plus d'un an
carole martineau a franchi le pas elle a
installé son atelier de décoration
intérieure dans ce bureau tout équipé
c'est vraiment un moteur que travailler
ici parce qu'on n'est pas seul là on
peut se faire quand même quelques pauses
on a déjeuné ensemble en plus ici on est
tous arrivés au même moment en janvier
2018 dont qui s'est créé vraiment une
synergie travailler dans une ambiance
conviviale en argument qui a séduit
cette société de courtage en travaux
intermédiaire pour les particuliers les
professionnels les deux associés ont
implanté leur bureau en novembre dernier
c'est une position qui est assez central
dans les yvelines qui est notre autre
secteur d'activité et de
d'intervention on est très près de la
très si on a besoin d'aller à paris
voilà et puis le cadre est très agréable
régulièrement la briqueterie ouvre ses
portes le samedi pour faire découvrir ce
lieu où selon ses locataires
il fait bon travailler à plaisir les
employés de sj bientôt fixés en juin
dernier les locaux de cette société
spécialisée dans le traitement des
pièces pour l'aéronautique étaient
détruits par un incendie est depuis le
site qui emploie 78 personne n'a pas
rouvert la direction veut délocaliser
son activité sur son second site à
villers cotterêts dans l'aisne et a donc
lancé un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
est décision qui ne passe pas auprès des
salariés qui ont saisi les prud'hommes
de versailles
un magistrat professionnel a entendu les
deux parties hier mardi a mis son
jugement en délibéré le verdict est donc
attendue pour mardi prochain
575 postes en alternance disponible dès
la rentrée de septembre
en ile de france dans les banques en
ile-de-france ces places ont été
commandés par les établissements haut à
cfpb école supérieure de la banque pour
en parler renault passerini bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le délégué régional
ile-de-france du cfpb école supérieure
de la banque un job dating est organisée
ce samedi de 10h à 17h sur votre campus
à la défense alors déjà quelques
éléments sur le cfpb quel est cet
organisme et quelle formation
propose-t-il alors c'est à une
institution qui a été créée il ya 90 ans
par les banques et dans le rôle
principal est d'accompagner les
collaborateurs de banques dans
l'accroissement de leurs compétences
professionnelles dans leur mobilité
professionnelle et dans leur diplomation
pour la formation continue pour les
salariés de danse et aussi pour
l'insertion des jeunes depuis à peu près
une vingtaine d'années le cfpb s'est
ouvert à l'alternance et on accompagne
plusieurs milliers 4000 jeunes chaque
année vers l'emploi
france entière dans les établissements
sur les types de formations financées
pour des jeunes qui souhaitent
travailler dans la banque mais aussi des
gens qui travaillent déjà dans la banque
ça c'est le cfpb c'est trente mille
banquiers à peu près formés chaque année
dont 4000 en alternance grandir pour des
jeunes qui veulent effectivement rentré
sur les métiers de la banque
quel type de formation du coup c'est
pour faire quoi justement qu'on passe
par le cfpb alors on passe avant tout
par le cfpb en alternance pour obtenir à
la fois un diplôme et un métier alors je
vais essayer de vous raconter un peu les
métiers de la bande en en deux temps
trois mouvements et c'est pas il et on
fera semblant normes mais globalement
vous avez 3 3 grandes familles de
métiers vous avez les métiers qui
concerne le commerce sur tous les
métiers de de relation clientèle tous
les métiers de convoi le métier des
agences physiques et autres vous avez
les métiers de
de marché mais qui sont aussi des
métiers de commerce le trading la
gestion d'actifs c'est aussi du commerce
et puis en contrepartie vous avez tous
les métiers du traitement des opérations
qui sont générés par le commerce ça qu'à
chaque fois que vous êtes dans une
agence qu'un une banque vous fait un
crédit par une fois après faut bien
gérer le crédit donc il ya des services
de back et middle office
les métiers du traitement de
l'information qui gère tout ce qui est
fait par le commerce et ensuite vous
avez une troisième famille c'est tous
les métiers de des fonctions support les
rh la stratégie l'audit le juridique
les directions informatiques la
conformité pour lesquelles on a un
master le big data pour lequel on ouvre
un master avec la sorbonne et c'est donc
on a nous côté formation maintenant donc
ça ce sont les métiers et côté formation
conforme au via des bts banque des
licences des masters a quasiment toutes
ces métiers des métiers d'entrée en fait
dans ces grandes familles que je vous ai
décrit justement là ses 575 postes en
alternance à qui s'adresse-t-il et ce
qu'ils font un niveau pour accéder à un
niveau requis pour accéder à ces postes
a oui alors il
il faut à la fois un niveau
scolaire bien sûr parce qu'on propose du
bts banque forcément faut déjà au moins
un niveau bac
on propose des licences il faut au moins
un niveau bac +2 et on propose des
masters il faut au moins un niveau bac +
3 ça c'est un niveau 10 ans le niveau
académique minimum requis à chaque à
chaque étape
maintenant il ya aussi une sélection
c'est à dire que tout le monde est
invité à découvrir et à rentrer dans
l'univers de la banque
mais comme le cfpb travail avec 140
partenariats universitaires
on a aussi côté universités pour ce qui
est des licences et des masters
voilà une étude un peu de la qualité
académique du dossier du jeune on peut
les faire ou ces formations est ce que
par exemple sur 50 ans de in je crois
qu'on peut on peut suivre ces formations
du cfpb tout à fait on est pas mal
implanté en île de france puisque on a à
peu près 16 16 partenariats
universitaires dont justement un avec
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines sur une licence pro banques
notent plusieurs possibilités sur le
territoire de l'île de france et je
rappelle qu'il ya un job dating qui se
tient ce samedi sur votre campus de la
défense alors pour refermer cette
interview je voulais parler du secteur
de la banque plus précisément est-ce que
déjà c'est un secteur qui embauche alors
je vous pose la question parce qu' à
cette actualité qui est tombé cette
semaine la société générale qui va
supprimer 1600 postes à travers le monde
750 2 en france est-ce qu du coup le
secteur de la banque
embauche aujourd'hui alors le secteur de
la banque
embauche
chaque année sur deux sur les trois
dernières années
16 17 et 18 à peu près 40 mille
personnes en est
chaque année dont un quart c'est à dire
à peu près dix mille alternant chaque
année donc un quart par la voie de
l'alternance
donc les efforts qui sont faits par la
profession bancaire pour à la fois
embauchés via l'alternance embaucher
tout court est ensuite former leurs
collaborateurs tout au long de leur
carrière est un énorme alors c'est on
peut voir dans la presse
ce que vous venez de dire mais ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que les banques
embauche les banques forment leurs
collaborateurs et propose des métiers
qui sont là en plus des métiers
extrêmement nouveaux et innovateurs pour
le futur peut-être de l'année mais ray
en numérisation des métiers tout à fait
alors pas de la numérisation des métiers
de la mairie qui n'ont plus voix lasse
un accompagnement par le numérique du du
métier de la relation clientèle ça c'est
sûr et donc je rappelle ce job dating ce
samedi sur le campus de la défense du
cfpb rendez vous de 10h à 17h c'est ça
exactement on a à peu près déjà 300
inscrits
mais si les les gens qui nous écoutent
ou
ou leur part la fin lors leurs enfants
veulent s'inscrire n'y a pas de souci il
faut aller sur cfpb point fr le site et
là je suis exactement à pardon j'avais
pu pas de souci merci à vous renault pas
de série ni d'être passé sur ce plateau
elle rappelle que vous êtes le délégué
régional ile-de-france du cfpb école
supérieure de la banque lancia des
cultures agnès varda nous quittait le 29
mars dernier en 2000 la réalisatrice
signait les glaneurs et la glaneuse et
parmi ces glaneurs justement un habitant
de la verrière alain fonteneau pour tv
78 t-il témoigne de son expérience vécue
avec la réalisatrice est le récit de
marie l'ania piché non j'ai comme
glanage l'année s'est ramassé après la
moisson en 2000 la cinéaste agnès varda
consacre un documentaire au glaneurs sur
le marché du boulevard edgar quinet à
paris elle rencontre alain fonteneau qui
ramassent des fruits et légumes
cet habitant de la verrière et vient
régulièrement glaner de la nourriture
avant de rentrer dans sa résidence
donner des cours d'alphabétisation
la documentariste est séduite par le
personnage elle l'intègre à son projet
ge aujourd'hui alain fonteneau vit
toujours au même endroit
c'était à la fin des marchés et elle m'a
posé la question vous êtes à un grand
mangeur qu'au père cible je dis oui
parce que perçu c'est très bon pour la
santé
et c'est à partir de ce moment là
qu'elle m'a posé la question si j'étais
d'accord pour être filmé deux ans après
agnès varda le retrouve pour une suite
des clameurs et la glaneuse alain je le
rencontre souvent depuis deux ans le
samedi je vais à la fin du marché et on
va prendre un café quand il a fini de
remplir son gros 500 cinémas
on va dire vous savez c'est comme un van
gogh
si vous voyez un van gogh à table et
bien
vous savez qu'il va de guingamp si vous
voyez un fils d'agnès varda
vous savez que c'est du agnès varda
c'est dix ans que voilà il ya une marque
voilà on voit un film agnès varda on
sait que celles fixées à nizar d'un sens
alors que qu'au départ on nous avait pas
dit que c'était c'était alain fonteneau
n'a pas changé depuis les années 2000
il donne toujours des cours de français
aux habitants de la verrière en 2016 il
sort son autobiographie
c'est le livre que j'ai écrit et une
erreur pis itinéraire bis retrace sa vie
son enfance à la campagne son travail
d'enseignant en biologie puis son
nouveau départ à paris où il rencontre
agnès varda laisse voir la sinopoli ce
documentaire il n'y aurait pas ce livre
parce que quinze ans après quelqu'un m'a
fait remarquer qu'il serait intéressant
que j'écrive une autobiographie de ma
vie moi je veux dit bon bah ma vie n'a
rien d'extraordinaire et elle m'a dit
tout s'il est même si une vie banale
elle est forcément original dans la
dernière fois qu'elles en font trop
croiser la réalisatrice est en 2016 pour
lui offrir son livre de cette grande
dame du cinéma il retient sa simplicité
et sa voix posée
son tableau la liberté guidant le peuple
est sans doute son oeuvre la plus connue
mais saviez vous que la toute première
commande passée au peintre eugène
delacroix a été passée donc dans les
yvelines cette toile et à orcemont et
elle fait la fierté de son un millier
d'habitants une découverte de ce
patrimoine signée marie ligne à pishin à
orcemont
une qui vient tout juste de dépasser les
1000 habitants réservé une surprise
d'envergure dans son église
saint-eutrope se cache un trésor dont
seul le maire peut nous donner l'accès à
bala il est saoul alors oui tout est
barricadé sous alarme le tableau lui
même et plus alarme le bâtiment est
valable un tableau pas en 1819 commandé
par un habitant est offert de tuer à la
commune on arrive dans l'église
et vous avez en face le tableau d'eugène
belgrand la vierge les mois sont
installés à gauche nous tél
dans son retable sur mesure la vierge
des moissons du même peintre que la
liberté guidant le peuple livrent tous
ses secrets
on peut manifestement ce se dire que
c'est quelque chose qu'il a réalisées
après la moisson puisqu'on voit des
gerbes au pied de la vierge et de
l'enfant liés à la pignada plus nyad
c'était une manière à cette époque-là de
lier les bottes de blé dans la sacristie
de l'église
on trouve même une boîte digne de
l'oeuvre d'art et ben en fait c'est son
sarcophage qui a été fait sur mesure et
donc le tableau est déposée de son
retard lorsqu'il part à l'étranger
il est installé dans un an ce sarcophage
là et il sert sa soeur bien sûr pour le
transporter là où il sera exposé ce qui
a été fait d'ailleurs récemment en 2004
au japon
je les emmenais d'abord le tableau
voyage et fait voyager le maire de la
commune où tout a commencé
c'est ici à la ferme du racine et que le
jeune peintre encore étudiant aux
beaux-arts reçoit sa toute première
commande
il est arrivé ici je ne la crois pour se
reposer tant donné qu'il était qu'il
était souffrant et donc il s'est
installé là aux racines est dans cette
ferme pour sûr pour s'y reposer c'est la
règle donc monsieur bouffier
cultivateurs propriétaires terriens
il est donc passé cette commande un
tableau acheté 15 francs dont le paysage
s'inspire directement des alentours de
la ferme alors naturellement dans la
mairie on le retrouve partout reconnu
trésor national
il est parfois amené à s'exposer ça plus
lointaines destinations remonte à 2004
au japon pour une exposition sur victor
hugo et le romantisme
j'étais surpris à chaque fois j'étais
toujours surpris de voir l'importance
qu'ils portaient à ce tableau 1
ne serait-ce que sur les affiches et
puis même même dans la salle
d'exposition où il était exposé on
rentrait sur la gauche il avait sa
petite salle à lui tout seul dans la
faune et et c'était vraiment une mise au
vert
mr d'or ce monde depuis 18 ans bernard
bourgeois s'improvise conservateur de
cette oeuvre d'art et même guide quand
des visites sont demandés mais fierté
pour le maire et son village
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant en place aux 7,8 débat urgence
climatique l'énergie nucléaire est elle
la solution c'est la question posée ce
soir par aurélie rose belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]